[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are gonna ask me and
tarek questions and we are going to
answer them it's gonna be fun like a
little party hence the name so if you
have a question just raise your hand
hi wavy hi wavy with the bow tie stand
up
what's up
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god
you look perfect
i have to say you're the cutest person i
ever laid eyes on
yes white me what do you have to ask
i find the show hilarious but also
educational so i was wondering if you
two were teachers what subject would you
most like
oh
yeah well now thing about tarik is
i was a teacher um
i taught
theater um
but i was a substitute teacher for a
while so i like
dabbled in a bunch of subjects the best
was jim cause
it's a scam y'all
being a gym teacher is great
uh all right today i'm gonna put a ball
in the middle of the court
y'all kill each other for it
the best
what would you teach
i would
try to teach
some language
to me that's the funnest thing
love languages you are insane at
learning languages i cannot add i can't
subtract
i can't find where i am on a map i can't
get from where i am to where i need to
be ever okay i can learn a language i
bet i bet i could learn a language a
full one that i've never heard of in
like a month can you correct my dutch
again we did we were speaking dutch
earlier today uh and uh the fluteton
house no
there there's this ah
it's a long story there's this um ride
at a park called the efteling and the
whole thing of the ride is that you're
in a haunted house this house this
cursed house and the guy who goes
amazing
that was probably the first dutch word
we ever learned yeah the house
they had
in the house
that is all the time we have for
question party this was great shouldn't
we do it again sometime
all right
you guys have been great thank you so
much
thanks you guys thanks for coming
[Applause]
you